the first Punic War was a massive
strategic struggle there's Urban sieges
Land battles and Monumental Naval
clashes
one of the best ways to think about the
first Punic War is as a circumnavigation
of Sicily
it began in 264 BC more or less at
masana in the Northeast and it moves
clockwise around the island until it
ends 20 odd years later in 241 BCE off
the coast of drapana which is today
trappiny in the northwest of Sicily over
more than two decades there are epic
triumphs and defeats for both sides but
also long periods of stalemate where
there's virtually no action
several of the most significant battles
come right at the beginning
the war's second year saw the Roman
senate coming to the decision to fill
Sicily with the combined forces of their
two Consular armies these armies added
up to a total of almost 40 000 soldiers
so this decision more than anything else
illustrates Rome's big Ambitions in
other words once they committed to the
conflict the Romans were moving to keep
the island into their own sphere of
influence the sheer enormity of the
Roman army quickly convinced several
cities to immediately declare for Rome
including Syracuse who abandoned their
erstwhile allies the carthaginians
believing Rome would have the upper hand
in the conflict to come
the Romans then set their sights on
agrakas
today's aggregento this was a prominent
Greek founded City on Sicily's rugged
South Coast that the carthaginians had
taken some decades previously carthage's
Allied cities in the west of Sicily were
Phoenician speaking originally like
Carthage and culturally linked to the
city itself
and when you look at the map you can see
the reason why
prevailing currents and winds means
there's an almost direct sea route from
the south coast of Sicily to the North
African Coast aggregenta was seen as a
buffer between the East and the west of
Sicily the Greeks in the East and the
carthaginian zones of influence in the
West
the arrival of both Syracuse and Roman
armies left the carthaginian Garrison in
the city overwhelmed by the looming
threat of their Collective power
Carthage did send an army to reinforce
the city made up of Celts and ligurians
and iberians
but this is a telling moment as you
really get the feeling that Carthage
found itself in a war it was completely
unprepared to fight
Carthage like most Hellenistic states
often recruited mercenaries for its
overseas fighting while using their own
citizens to defend home territory and to
crew their navies
ancient sources have tended to
exaggerate the impacts that this had but
it's true that carthage's armies were
seen as their weakest point
the bulk of their armies consisted of
men from their allies in North Africa
and Iberia
supplemented by soldiers For Hire from
across the Mediterranean because we have
to understand that soldiering was a
profession in the ancient world and to
work for Carthage could be lucrative as
they were known for their High rates of
pay
but raising an army was slow and this
was a quick and unexpected attack
so it took time for the carthaginians to
reinforce their Garrison in the besieged
city
agrigento was a big ancient city and the
Roman blockade had trapped almost 50 000
people within the walls
the Romans also disrupted the Harvest
which meant there was little food for
the city's inhabitants
famine came soon after The Siege and
only added to people's troubles when
carthage's new Army arrived it
surrounded the Roman troops
the carthaginian commander Hano was
conscious of the desperate situation
within the city and pressed battle with
the Romans quickly to try to relieve the
population
so we're told that it was a very close
fight but in the end the Romans came out
as Victors and forced the carthaginian
Army to retreat to the nearby city of
haraclea
so after a five-month long Siege the
carthaginian commander at agrogento
chanced an evacuation of his Garrison
his actions spared his soldiers
but left the city's populace without any
protection
Rome's troops stormed and sacked the
city and many of his people were
enslaved
The Spoils of their Victory were sent to
Rome and paraded through the streets the
people who had been enslaved were
paraded as well and the statues and gold
from the city that was soon to be
renamed agri-gentum in its Latin name
according to polybius the Roman people
were astonished and delighted by the
riches that were looted from this
Sicilian City and soon the whole of the
Roman population were heartily in
support of the war for the whole island
now this is a really important part of
the story because two key theories of
Rome's rise to World Domination are
prevalent in scholarship and it's really
important for this period to understand
one explanation
and the one that the Romans like to put
forward was that they had won their
empire just by accident
they were just accidental imperialists
they happen to be so good at conquest
and ruling while their enemies were so
perfidious and foolish that the Empire
just fell into their hands
the other explanation is that the Romans
were the most bloodthirsty and Savage
Barbarian conquerors at the Hellenistic
world had ever seen
and it couldn't cope with their
single-minded determination
Melody lies somewhere in the middle
all sides were fighting for the sake of
advancement in Rome's case their
consistent successes in expanding
throughout Italy over the previous
Century had really brought about their
Zeal for Conquest
as well as the economic boost that
constant Warfare was providing them
this was embodied in their politics
where competition amongst Elite families
drove further expansion to such an
extent that there was never an
alternative it was just how the Roman
system was
the Romans did have a different attitude
from the beginning though their ruling
class gained wealth and power from
Conquest it was a key part of elite male
identity in Rome to be a general who
fought and conquered indeed the elite
competed amongst themselves to outdo
each other on the battlefield
subsequently the Roman senate usually
issued peace negotiations and settled
for nothing less than total Victory so
the result was a Snowball Effect when it
came to Wars which tended to escalate
dramatically in Roman hands
we know so much less about the
carthaginian system and its Traditions
that it's difficult to analyze their
intentions
they had inherited an advanced Naval
prowess and culture thanks to their
location on the sea and seafaring
Phoenician ancestors
the city's influence relied heavily on
the sea making ships carthage's primary
form of communication with Allied cities
this would explain why a great deal of
the state's fortunes appear to have come
from Naval trade as well as their
overall control of ports and duties that
came as well
as a result Carthage gained reputation
that highlighted their Naval superiority
but this is often overstated because
Carthage was much more than just a naval
City it sat on Africa's North Coast in a
wealthy and prosperous part of the world
with Rich agricultural resources its
wine was celebrated it's agricultural
technology studied around the
Mediterranean nevertheless the way the
carthaginians perceive themselves had a
lot to do with the sea and how that
their citizens managed their Navy
whether it was the manufacturing of
ships the mechanisms of the ports or the
level of seamanship from the sailors the
carthaginian naval culture touched all
levels of the population if we look at
the naval exploits a number of ships
employed by the carthaginians in the 3rd
Century BC alone it's very likely that
the needs of the Navy could not have
been met by citizens
or just allies and mercenaries and
slaves would also needed to have been
employed on their warships
this is equally true of the Romans
there are indications that carthage's
Navy was enhanced further by privately
sponsored Naval organizations as well
this means that citizens would build an
outfit and manage ships for specialized
operations
for instance in 250 BC a man who is
known as Hannibal the rhodian
an admiral of Carthage and his
exceptional crew managed to successfully
avoid a blockade set by the Romans in
the city of Lily bayam which is today's
marsala in Sicily we're told that the
rodian had fitted the ships personally
now modern marsala also provides us with
some wonderful evidence of carthaginian
shipbuilding prowess in this period
there were two Punic ships found off the
coast of Sicily in the early 1970s
excavated by the pioneering underwater
archaeologist honor Frost
one is called a librarian which is a
small Galley ship used for raiding and
patrols and it was likely sunk by force
at some point near the end of the first
Punic War
it's an incredible find and it's on
display today in the maritime museum in
Marcella and it's provided us with a
wealth of information about the
construction and the building techniques
used by the shipwrights of Carthage
so the preservation of calligraphy on
this ship in the Phoenician Phoenician
Punic script
is amazing and indicates there was a
kind of prefabrication with the separate
parts of that ship and each part was
lettered to allow for a portable
Construction
on the other hand
polybius tells us the Romans had
virtually no experience with Naval
Warfare at the outbreak of the first
Punic War
at the moment they crossed to Sicily
we're told they had to borrow deck ships
and warships from their allies
this may well be a prime example of how
the ancient sources from this time tend
to massage the story of the wars with
Carthage
numerous Scholars have challenged the
idea that Rome had no Naval experience
at the outset of the war
they very likely had at least some and
of course their new allies like the
syracusans were important Naval Powers
but it's this heroic narrative for
polybius and later historians to portray
the Romans as The Underdogs who through
their cleverness and adaptability beat
the aggressors at their own game
whatever the case by the time the first
big naval battle of the first Punic War
took place off of my life which is
today's milazzo in the year 260 BC it
seems the Romans had managed to
construct a navy and train competent
soldiers and captains
the Romans we are told had based the
construction of their Navy on a captured
carthaginian ship
they had however made an important
adaptation and this was something that's
called the corvus which means crow in
English and it's a kind of retractable
boarding bridge that was attached to the
prow of a ship
the corvus was rigged to the front of
the Roman ship and could swing around
and drop onto the attacking Ship by
means of a rogue
it was about four feet wide and 36 feet
long and it had a spike that which would
allow it to attach to the death of an
enemy ship
so by locking the hulls together
the Roman Marines could then fight their
way across on the corvus and killer
captured the enemy crew
now this changed the Dynamics of Naval
Warfare which until this point were all
about ramming and sinking enemy ships
but the Romans now had a way to use
their Superior troops to their advantage
at sea
now even the mightiest carthaginian ship
could be captured if the Roman Marines
got close enough to board it
it seems to have made all the difference
at the Battle of my life despite the
carthaginian seamanship and Naval
pedigree they were thoroughly defeated
with many dozens of their ships captured
with this new Roman tactic
and in fact what was counter-intuitive
about the first Punic War was that the
carthaginian performance at Sea
continued to be
pretty abysmal
historians have perhaps not only then
maybe exaggerated Roman inexperience at
the start of the war but we might
consider that they overstated military
prowess of carthage's Navy too
and we might want to think about the
carthaginian Navy more as a kind of
Merchant Marine in origin
yet despite successes at Sea the
situation in Sicily ground down to a
long war of attrition
the Island's mountainous and has
traditionally favored Defenders though
the Romans had captured agregento
further advances through Sicily were
difficult sieges spanning years and
there was limited ability to bring the
full force of the Roman army to bear on
the entrenched carthaginian positions
decisive Naval battles also eluded the
Romans with the skilled carthaginian
fleets after my life knowing to avoid
total capture so they could continue to
harass Roman shipping and transport
fleets
the war had been dragging on for nearly
a decade
when the Romans decided in 256 BCE to
change their strategy and send a fleet
to invade North Africa directly
the carthaginians recognized this as an
in big impending threat and responded
and what resulted is possibly the
largest naval battle in history
with somewhere between
400 and 700 ships involved
remember this is an era where rowing
provides the main power and
maneuverability for ships
the upper end of this estimate means
there could have been as many as a
hundred thousand rowers Marines and
sailors involved in the engagement
now these are outrageous numbers
the entire population of Rome might only
have been around 250 000 in this time
frame same with Carthage
so it means both sides were committing
huge amounts of resources and human and
material to this conflict
all indications suggest that the battle
which took place off of a place called
Cape economis was closely fought but
ultimately the carthaginians lost it and
now faced a full-scale invasion of their
home territory
the Roman Consul in charge of the
invasion was a man named Marcus attilius
regulus and he landed more than fifteen
thousand soldiers on carthaginian soil
and began marching towards Carthage
itself
several towns and cities fell to the
Romans including Tunes which is modern
Tunis just 10 miles from the capital
obviously Carthage is facing a desperate
situation
they attempt to recall their forces from
Sicily to protect the Homeland but with
the fall of Tunis they sue for peace
with the Romans yet regulus's terms are
so outrageous and harsh that Carthage
has little choice but to fight on
the war has taken a huge toll on
Carthage by this point
we can see this in the archaeological
site of carecoin especially clearly this
is a small town on the North coast of
Africa that got its wealth in the
ancient world through the production of
a unique and highly valued purple dye
if it's dye didn't make it special
enough
in modern times karakowan is among the
few fully Punic sites to have been
Unearthed this matters
because this tiny City offers us a close
look into the everyday urban life
and standard of living that came with it
during carthage's rule in North Africa
for this town which subsisted as well on
fishing and agriculture those standards
are particularly High
the inhabitants of carecoin were
incredibly organized and resided in
small well-built homes many of these
homes had floors lined with mosaics and
this is pretty extraordinary in the 3rd
Century BC
and had indoor plumbing
extra extraordinary for the time
this was very much an all mod cons kind
of place yet it seems that regulus's
Invasion directly led to the total
desertion of this small City
those of the population who weren't
amongst the 20 000 taken back to Rome as
captives to be sold in slavery anyone
left moved away
despite its grisly fate it remains a
stunning location and offers anybody who
bothers to visit it a glimpse of the
invasion and the ruin it brought Upon A
thriving Punic town
we see the evidence of the devastation
as well in the currency of Carthage from
the mid to 50s BCE we see consistent
debasement in the silver quantity and
the carthaginian shekels and its
bicycles
are much less valuable than they were at
the start of the war
now this is a clear sign that the
economy is in Decline they are
desperately minting coins without the
precious metal content to back them up
to try to keep paying their armies
facing total annihilation
the carthaginians turned to a Spartan
named xanthipus to reform and defend
their Capital against the Romans
the carthaginian army that we think
about when we think about Hannibal
begins now
santhipus reorganized the Army and
sought to better depoloi the biggest
advantages the carthaginians had against
the Romans
these were their fast and hard-hitting
Cavalry and their elephants which they
had just begun to experiment with after
purus had first used them in the Western
Mediterranean
zentipus puts these two elements at the
heart of the carthaginian battle
strategy and sought open planes on which
to use them to the fullest advantage
against the Romans
at the Battle of Tunis in 255 BCE
xanthipus's reorganized Army is put to
the test results are devastating for the
Romans
the Roman infantry had no answer to the
elephants now deployed at the front of
the carthaginian lines who Stampede
through the Roman ranks and caused
confusion across the battlefield
the carthaginian Cavalry is then able to
sweep in and outflank the Roman lines
weakening them so the carthaginian
Infantry moves in to finish the job
now this is one of the few carthaginian
field victories in the first Punic War
but it was a critical one nearly all of
the fifteen thousand Roman troops of
regulus's invasions are wiped out we're
told
a huge Roman Fleet is sent back to
evacuate the survivors and to stabilize
the situation
but Upon returning to Sicily it was
wrecked before it reached the island in
a storm
and it's reported that 384 ships were
sunk and tens of thousands of men lost
at sea it's an almost inconceivable
Naval Disaster by today's standards and
certainly an exaggeration
this does emphasize though just how
dangerous sea going was in this period
and ironically it may have been that
corvus that made Roman ships
particularly unseaworthy leaving them
vulnerable to capsize in rough weather
so Carthage had survived total defeat
but only just the war is far from Over
the economic toll on both sides was epic
and neither wants to capitulate
in these later stages of the war the
Romans abandoned the idea of the
outright capture of Carthage and the
focus shifts back to Sicily and
particularly its western coast
here were the traditionally carthaginian
Allied cities of penomous drapana and
Lily bayam which the Romans now had in
their crosshairs
the defense of the west of Sicily in 247
BCE would fall to a young commander and
Scion of one of carthage's military
Elite families whose name was hamelkar
barkha he is sent to take command in
Sicily with just a handful of ships and
troops with the goal of holding the
Romans off at all costs
in that very same year with the fate of
Carthage on a knife's edge hamelkar's
son Hannibal Barca is born in Carthage
foreign
[Music]